sur ce plateau christophe crépin vient
de nous rejoindre bonjour vous êtes
porte parole du syndicat france police
policiers en colère on a entendu au
micro de guimard aussi à l'instant un
pompier évoqué le chiffre d'un blessé
est ce que vous vous avez des chiffres
concernant les éventuels s'agit pas de
site de chiffres ont été communiqués par
la préfecture je sais que j'ai de mes
collègues qui seront baissées je sais
qu'il y a eu un blessé léger du côté des
pompiers
mais je vous dire que mme asayama parité
syndicale france police policiers en
colère nous sommes avec les peaux les
pompiers qui ont des doléances qui nous
sont pour nous légitime à la sarre du
fait que les violences nous avons
toujours dénoncé aujourd'hui les
instructions de la préfecture de police
sont très claires il faut vraiment qu'il
y ait vraiment en parle de possibilité
d'avoir deux classes ou quoi que ce soit
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
manifestation étant qu'elle a pris d'une
manière très serrée des dérives
dispositif policier justement
aujourd'hui comment quel est le
dispositif policier justement gg des
gendarmes obligé d des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité et aussi des
dispositifs de la préfecture de police
qui sont tout au long des deux chiffres
comme ça parce que en fait c'est
évolutif en fait on avait des gens qui
sont tout le long de la manifestation
là on va arriver sur la fin de cortège
sur le fait qu'ils veuillent puis
laiteries sur le périphérique
je pense que c'est inconcevable parce
que qu'ils exposent eux mêmes leur vie
et ils s'exposent à des complications
assez conséquente
concernant leurs doléances pour nous
elles sont louables mais faut pas
oublier une chose pour vos
téléspectateurs c'est que en fait les
pompiers travaillent sous instruction du
ministère intérieur comme la police nous
on n'est pas du tout opposée au complet
au contraire on apprécie beaucoup de
travailler main dans la main
et là aujourd'hui la préfecture de
police ou donne des instructions qui
sont très clairs et qu'ils sont
justement de ne pas de ne pas laisser à
la porte ouverte à quelques les actions
que ce soit
dont celle que nous sommes en train de
voir sa compagne images avec des
maladies qui essayaient de pénétrer sur
le boulevard périphérique comme ça c'est
inconséquent parce que déjà il faut
comprendre une chose qu'on adule sur le
port des banquiers qui sont des pompiers
comme moi des professionnels qui sont
tous les jours à la caserne de
champerret août et sérieuse ainsi
s'agissant des deux centrales 7000
pompiers en france voilà
mais c'est leur doléance ce sont des
gens qui sont dans la société civile
important et qui revêtent l'uniforme
pour pouvoir porter assistance à nos
citoyens donc leurs doléances pour nous
sauce aux sons d'une alliance qui sont
louables revêtent leurs uniformes venait
de dire une histoire tout le temps et
qui sont annulés à une certain un
certain moment où par exemple vous avez
un accident de voie publique
hop ils quittent leur travail ils
mettent leurs uniformes ils viennent
porter assistance
vous avez un feu ces séjours de choses
mais uniforme d'habitude uniforme auquel
et certains ont mis le feu
tout à l'heure pour soutenir
symboliquement envoyé en fait rien on a
quand même une grosse fracture sociale
dans notre pays il serait temps
peut-être que le gouvernement se rendre
compte que des métiers qui sont des
métiers de sûreté de sécurité et
d'assistance auprès du public ne sont
pas tout à fait heureux en fait il ya
peut-être une réponse à apporter
alors l'occasion des retraites fait que
maintenant tous les corps sont en
discordance par rapport au gouvernement
le fait de voir des images comme celles
ci en direct ça vous fait quoi
ça fait mal au coeur je sais pas ce que
nous travaillons main dans la main avec
les pompiers la police nationale les
pompiers ont elles-mêmes
on a le ministère de l'intérieur qui
nous dirigent en fait et nous
travaillons vraiment mal ni main dans la
main et quand il nous parle que les
pompiers sont agressés par koti koti
interviennent nous on vit ça au
quotidien ou d'aujourd'hui on obligé
d'escorter les camions de pompiers pour
qu'ils puissent rentrer dans certains
endroits on a quand même une société qui
a complètement évolué tout ce qui
représente la société le
le pouvoir enfin le l'autorité est mis
en péril
je vous propose christophe crépin de on
voulait repartir du côté de monnaie à
mouthe pour prendre le pouls sur place
de cette manifestation a priori devoir
patienter un petit peu pour retrouver
mona amoud et lors il ya également un
guillemin rossi qui est sur place donc
dispositif important du côté berthet
france poursuivre cette mobilisation des
pompiers plusieurs milliers d'entre eux
qui défilent donc de nouveau aujourd'hui
pour dénoncer le manque d'effectifs et
de reconnaissance de leur peau de leur
profession ils réclament également des
garanties pour leur retraite d'ailleurs
christophe crépin alors qu'on est
toujours en train de voir ces images du
côté de la place de la nation vers le
boulevard périphérique
la porte de vincennes plus précisément
et
et manifeste forcément contre la réforme
des retraites également alors que demain
il y à une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation nationale contre la réforme
des retraites à l'appel d'une
intersyndicale
qu'est ce qui va se passer demain j'ai
envie de dire 24 heures après ce qui se
passe maintenant je suis pas devin mais
je pense que les gens ne veulent pas de
cette forme de de passation de pouvoir
en force sur les retraites je pense
qu'il faut qu'on trouve vraiment essayé
de ce après que le gouvernement qui peut
trouver ça mais concertation entre les
représentants du peuple
et puis l'open et puis le pouvoir qui
fait parce qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est cette réforme est très
mal vécue elle n'est pas vécue comme une
justice
elle est vécue comme une injustice nous
mêmes la police on n'est pas d'accord
avec la retraite peut-être qu'on nous
les deux pauses on est sûre on n'a
aucune garantie aucune garantie mon ce
qu'on veut c'est l'aliment police
gendarmerie
est ce qu'on leur a pour l'interrogation
on est des policiers régalien au fait ne
travaille que nous devons faire vous le
voyez malheureusement mais nous sommes
de tout coeur avec des gens qui ont des
vrais doléances et les pompiers qui sont
issus de la société civile qui sont des
gens comme vous et moi qui mets qui met
qui mettent leurs uniformes et qui
mettent leur vie en péril pour nous
sauver sont des gens qui méritent le
plus profond respect et d'avoir aussi le
respect de la nation
puis de là les gouvernants évidemment
christophe crépin vous êtes toujours
présent avec nous sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
du syndicat de police france police
policiers en colère qui m'a rossi a
évoqué des des grenades on a vu
d'ailleurs sur ces images on voit des
fusées fumigènes mais me concernant les
grenades quelles sont ces types de
grenades qui sont employés des grenades
lacrymogènes des grenades de
désencerclement des grenades cli f4 on
entend du ministre castaner parler du
retrait de
de ces fameuses grenades qui ont blessé
des communications en fait la glnf 4
nice depuis le début commercialisés dont
cola une grenade qui est sans tnt
intérieur sans explosif mais ils furent
technique est exactement le même
moi j'engage home les manifestants ne
pas essayer de reprendre des grenades
qui ont été lancée parce que là vraiment
il est qu'ils exposent leur vie et nous
mêmes nous avons eu des blessés dans nos
rangs avec des jets de grenades mais la
guille f 4 n'existe plus nous avons des
grenades de désencerclement qui font du
bruit et qui au fond un effet de souffle
je ne sais pas quel quels sont les
droits qui sont utilisés je pense que
cela est certainement dû lacrymogène
pour essayer de canaliser pour éviter
qu'ils aient trop de débordements mais
mais voilà quoi en fait et on aperçoit
ici justement un fumigène qui a été
projeté par dessus la barrière de
sécurité c'est parcours donc anti
émeutes pour éviter que certains
manifestants ne passe de l'autre côté
pour rejoindre le boulevard périphérique
il ya eu un tout à l'heure en début
d'après midi du côté du périphérique a
été emprunté brièvement par par les
pompiers inadmissible selon la
préfecture de police de paris christophe
crépin feller également en début de
cortège qui a eu
des périodes de tension entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
avec a priori deux cents à trois cents
pompiers qui aurait voulu prendre un
chemin annexes non déclarés comment
est-ce que ça son terrain en tant que
policier vous vous gérez morgien
exactement la même façon de poser ses
passions district de ly qui galère qui a
été pré établies soient respectées parce
qu'on veut pas être partout et donc en
fait les personnes qui ont voulu
s'extraire ils ont été vite roues oui
dans le chemin de la manifestation
déclarée
je ne sais pas quelles étaient leurs
intentions et il faut qu'ils restent
dans le parcours qui est déclarée
regardez ces images en direct avec des
manifestants qui s'agglutinent en
direction donc de ces barrières
anti-émeute avec sa situation semblait
calme que accès au périphérique pour eux
c'est peut-être valeur symbolique mais
ils mettent ils exposent leur vie ont
ils exposent leur vie et des véhicules
qui circulent il y a il y a
une possibilité de pouvoir des accidents
très graves je pense que ça sert à rien
qu'ils excluent périphériques qui
peuvent très bien être entendu là d'où
ils sont justement concernant le
dénouement entendu guimard aussi notre
envoyé spécial sur place
être dans l'interrogation selon vous
coûte de la dispersion ou dénouement
j'espère qu'ils vont comprendre que
toute façon la violence n'apporte rien
même si nous ne parité ça lesquels on
est tout à fait a vécu dans les
doléances qu'ils expriment leur foi vrai
statut il leur faut qu'ils soient et
reconnue dans la dangerosité du métier
qu'ils exercent même s'ils sont et
surtout ce sont des volontaires parce
que c'est beau aujourd'hui d'avoir des
gens qui sont volontaires forte pour
porter assistance à leurs citoyens de
notre beau pays en fait mais
je ne sais pas quelle sera la décision
du ministre l'intérieur j'espère qu'il
aura entendu écouté qui prendra un vrai
statut pour ces gens qui l'ont eric
puisqu'on le rappellent les syndicats
reçus dans l'après midi au ministère de
l'intérieur pour discuter de tous ces
sujets en rappellant que la prime de feu
n'a pas été revalorisé depuis 1990 c'est
l'une des demandes une des
revendications des des pompiers
aujourd'hui à noter que le préfet de
police de paris
didier lallement
sur le twitter de la préfecture de
police de police demande aux
organisateurs d'après à la dispersion de
la manifestation
christophe crépin vous êtes toujours
présent sur sur ce plateau vous êtes un
rappel le porte parole du syndicat
france police policiers en colère vous
disiez tout à l'heure ils ne passeront
pas c'est sûr quand on voit certaines
images on a l'impression que les portes
elle va si un petit peu en fait c'est
pas des plaintes en fait ce sont des
great qui sont oui de gens des véhicules
dans fait qu'ils sont là j'ai pour
éviter que il ya affranchissement c'est
des grilles qui sont hyper sony d'un
c'est le système qui fait que les unes
avec les autres font un mur qui sera
franchie ça devait de toute façon je
pense qu'ils passent compensation parce
que muselin alors il peut peut-être pas
passées par sept par par ce chemin mais
selon la préfecture de police
de paris certains manifestants pénètrent
dans des immeubles privés cours de
vincennes afin de contourner le
dispositif pour atteindre le
périphérique est ce que ça c'est
possible vous sans policiers qu'est ce
que vous faites pour empêcher les les
pompes hier et qui a fait des petits
groupes d'intervention de la compagnie
dopc de paris qui ont dû les envies les
bords et qui vont un peu qu'ils vont les
interpellés pendant ce matin
tous complices à proximité aux 27 g
compagnies républicaines de sécurité
je pense pas que d'en passer par là il
essaye c'est le jeu en fait un power oui
je pense pas qu'ils passent pourri comme
vous vos comment donc vos caméras mal le
fond voire en fait c'est une solidarité
totale avec ce avec les barres pour
éviter justement qu'ils puissent passer
en fait un on a perçu tout à l'heure sur
d'autres images aux alentours de 16h 5d
gilet jaune présent au sein de cette
manifestation n'a perçu jérôme rodriguez
et phau 6 lellouche de figure
emblématique du mouvement des gilets
jaunes
le fait qu'ils aient déjà les jours de
présence du corps peut s'amuser comme
quoi la toute façon les pompiers sont
ici de la justice civile et y portent
assistance à la france en fait donc
léger et on essaye de récupérer tout ce
qui est doléances au pouvoir se faire
entendre également quand on fait un
léger les jaunes pour nous nous pensions
qu'ils avaient violé ans qui étaient
isolés ayant ce légitime après c'est
parti dans n'importe quel sens et on a
eu des bad blocks qui sont venus se
greffer mais je suis pas surpris qu'il
déjoue les jours qui viennent pour
essayer de récupérer pour essayer d être
en cause toute façon geng he est très
grande fracture sociale dans le prix
pense que la seule réponse qui peut être
apprécié par le gouvernement
groupe i feel de pompiers assez énervé
tenter toujours d'enfance et c'est par
foncer ces barricades pour tenter de
changer la donne ce sont des gens qui
ont un niveau sportif est très
conséquent
c'est des gens qui attirent tout sur le
physique ils sont très très très
physique